if you have arthritis
whether it's rheumatoid arthritis
osteoarthritis
or gout you need to watch this video i'm
going to show you the number one best
herb that is in your backyard right now
that can greatly help arthritis or an
achy muscle or joint pain
and we're looking at it right here okay
i'm going to show you what it looks like
a little bit closer here if you can see
it
i don't know if you can see that okay
this is stingy nettle
okay stinging nettle
i just took a little bit from the woods
and put it into a pot and it grows like
crazy you barely need to water it now
the word nettle comes from the
derivation anglo-saxon
which means needle and the latin word
for
to burn because
these have millions of tiny little
hyperdermic
needles
on the underneath the leaves and on the
stems
that when you touch it it injects their
little glass-like tube
and breaks off this
shaft of chemicals like one is uh formic
acid which the little ants can bite you
and have the same stinging sensation
or if you're stung by a bee it has
formic acid and so the formic acid can
cause a little bit of stinging pain it's
not too bad but it can definitely create
some pain and then there's histamine
substances in there there's serotonin
acetylcholine
and probably a thousand other chemicals
and they don't know exactly what
chemical is creating the
anti-inflammatory effect but it could
even be your own immune system reacting
to this these chemicals and reducing
inflammation that way we don't know all
we know is when you expose this to an
inflamed joint whether it's on your
fingers or your big toe
or your shoulder or your knee it can
greatly reduce the inflammation and pain
and so it's fairly safe
it's extremely available it's all over
the place it grows like a weed very low
cost and it's even edible there's
actually a lot of nutrition in this
plant it has calcium it has selenium it
has the b vitamins it has vitamin c
vitamin e some people put in their soup
some people make a pesto out of it some
people make a tea out of it or put in
their salad but in this video i'm going
to recommend using it topically and i'm
not recommending going out and getting a
supplement i'm recommending
just finding it in your backyard
or in the woods or you might want to
consider growing it if you have
arthritis because if you use it on a
regular basis you won't have arthritis
and it's interesting because i talked to
a farmer
who had
very severe arthritis i mean he was
basically crippled and
he got in his riding lawnmower and he
was cutting his lawn
and he ran over a bee's nest okay
and the bees
came out
and started stinging him
all over his knees okay now don't ask me
why they just focus on the knees but
that's exactly where he had his
arthritis i mean they could have
actually killed him if they stung them
all over his body but they focused on
one body part which happened to be
where most of his arthritis was and so
he attempts to run away and starts
running really fast and realizes that he
has no pain no arthritis i mean here's a
guy that was basically crippled could
barely walk and he's running away from
the effect of a bee sting so there's
some interesting data on even b venom
for arthritis and i'm not convinced it's
just formic acid but there's something
in the bee sting and certain plants that
create an anti-inflammatory effect and
what's cool about the stinging nettle is
that it's been used for a very long time
the romans used it the egyptians used it
for arthritis and you can also use like
the root
for
prostate enlargement and you can use the
leaves for hay fever
allergies
things to help reduce histamines and so
it gives off like antihistamine
properties and the other thing that's
pretty interesting about this plant is
that it blocks a certain enzyme called
aromatase aromatase turns your
testosterone into estrogen
so this is basically an aromatase
inhibitor so it's really good for people
that have too much estrogen both in men
and females and so as the world becomes
more estrogenic because you know you
have plastics out there you have
chemicals that all mimic estrogen things
like this are going to be more and more
popular to help reduce the
the massive estrogen effect that's
occurring in both
men and women and so what i would
recommend
is you take a glove like this
and then grab
like some leaves off here and then just
apply it to wherever you have arthritis
whether it's on your hands or your knees
if the stinging might bother you but
when you apply the leaf topically to an
area of your body you have arthritis
let's say you have arthritis in your
hands
and you start to feel a little stinging
you want to keep rubbing and break some
of the green chlorophyll from the plant
into the hands because there's a lot of
additional chemicals and
anti-inflammatories that will quickly
counter any type of
pain that you might experience from the
little needle sensation but you're going
to notice really quickly that the
inflammation is going to go right down
and you'll start noticing like your your
stiffness will go away the pain will go
away whether it's in your hands a
shoulder a knee or even your big toe and
i'd recommend using this like several
times a day until you're actually
pain-free so i just wanted to share a
very simple remedy that you might have
sitting in your backyard now if you have
not seen my video
on fasting
for inflammation and pain i put it up
right here check it out